in eastern ukraine the town of
trusteonets has been retaken by
ukrainian troops but with much of it
lying in ruins
the russians departed after a month of
heavy fighting while many people took
shelter
we have spent 30 days in the basement
with small children who've been shaking
until now
the russians left behind military
hardware and allegations of widespread
abuse
they came to our houses intimidated
people and kicked them out of their
homes they took everything from us
mobile phones guns food everything
in the past week ukrainian forces have
been recapturing towns and villages
around the capital kiev while russian
forces have also been withdrawing or
being pushed back in the north east and
south west
it's thought the russians will now
concentrate efforts in the east of the
country and mount a final push to take
the besieged city of mariupol
efforts to open a humanitarian corridor
into the ruined city continue the
international committee of the red cross
says in addition to getting people out
of mariupol it's vitally important for
the corridor to be used to get
humanitarian aid in the icrc says it's
prepared to lead the effort but only if
the two warring sides can guarantee the
safe passage of the convoy the western
city of levive is providing refuge for
thousands of people who have fled the
fighting around kiev and other cities
further east people like olha and her
two children who now attend regular
activity sessions provided by this
children's library
right now this is the only and best way
to keep my kids and myself busy
to keep them distracted
this class is being led by a teacher who
was forced to flee a town near the front
line in the east
they're happy they're playing and their
joy is my joy
art sessions here are aimed at tackling
the trauma they may have experienced
from the fighting president vladimir
putin invariably portrayed as the
villain elsewhere in this library
volunteers work on camouflage netting
for ukrainian forces
across the border in the neighboring
russian region of briansk returning
paratroopers are given a hero's welcome
instead of pulling forces back from the
fighting as moscow has previously
announced western observers suspect
russia might simply be rotating units
and preparing for a new phase in this
war
rob mcbride al-jazeera leve
let's get an update with imran khan
who's joining us from the ukrainian
capital akiv imran over to you
two very big explosions in the last four
hours the first one took place around
four o'clock local happened not too far
away from here and then one again about
an hour ago uh both in the same area
those explosions took place uh in the
center of kiev that's the first time
certainly since i've been reporting uh
that um artillery or missiles or rockets
we're not entirely sure what type of
ordinance was used has come this close
to the city center now this all comes
after the russians on tuesday said they
were going to relieve the pressure on
kiev because they understood that there
were decision makers in place by
decision makers they mean the government
frankly so the fact that this has now
happened and it happened twice in the
space of a few hours is very
disconcerting for many we don't know
what building has been hit there's lots
of speculation on social media but the
fact that we weren't allowed to go uh to
the site of the explosion which we have
been able to do in the past suggests
that it's a sensitive location but
uh this all comes like i say um as the
ukrainians are very worried about what
the russians are actually up to and this
has been backed up by the nato secretary
general ian stoltenberg who's actually
said uh a withdrawal is taking place
from key but
he sees it as much more as a
repositioning a regrouping and perhaps
even a resupply for a new phase of the
war whether that comes to kiev or
whether they're going to concentrate
in the east and in the donbass region is
unclear but he also says that the
russians are keeping up their pressure
on kievan we're seeing evidence of that
almost every single day every single day
since that announcement there have been
shelling artillery missiles rockets
hitting the outskirts of key bravery on
the other side as well so there's a lot
of pressure still on the capital uh and
that is concerning residents and but
more there's a political issue here as
well for the ukrainian government every
time they seem to make headway with the
russians something like this happens and
it's increasingly frustrating them and
something they are now talking about
publicly thank you so much imran khan
reporting from kiev